في ظل التغيرات المجتمعيه التي نشهدها
اعداد الاشخاص غير القادرين على ارتباط
بشريك حياه والدخول في علاقه عاطفيه يزداد
يوما بعد يوم فالعثور على الزوج المثالي
لم يعد يكفي بحسب دراسه حديثه من جامعه
ريولا بولايه الامريكيه بل من الضروري
امتلاك مهارات الحفاظ على العلاقات
الرومانسيه الدراسه اشارت الى ان مراحل
الزواج اصبحت مختلفه تماما في عصرنا
الحالي فالافراد الان يفتقرون مهارات
كثيره تؤدي لنجاح لارتباط العاطفي وتكوين
الاسر منها مهارات المغازله والذكاء
العاطفي والنقاش والاستراتيجيه لحل
الخلافات واداره المشكلات الاستراتيجيه في
حل خلافات اعجبني ذكاء العاطفي مما يجعل
كثيرون يفضلون العزوبيه طواعيه وليس
اجبارا المزيد حول صعوبه الارتباط ايجاد
الشريك في وقتنا الحالي مع سهى جميل
[موسيقى]
ما بين القفص الذهبي وشبك العزوبيه تدور
احداث ملايين البشر
فحلموا الارتباط بشريك الحياه لم يعد
الاجمل لدى كثيرين حيث كشفت دراسه حديثه
ان ثمه ما يزيد من اعداد الاشخاص غير
قادرين على الارتباط
فالتغيرات والمجتمعيه القت بظلالها على
الزوج المثالي اضافه لضعف مهارات الحفاظ
على العلاقه من اجواء الرومانسيه وتناغم
واتفاق العزوبيه اذا قرار وليس خيار قرار
يتخطى به كثيرون مؤسسه الزواج التي يجب ان
تقوم على اسس النقاش والتفاوض وحل الخلاف
والمغازله الزوجيه والعواطف الدراسه اضافت
ايضا بان اسباب صعوبه العثور على شريك
حياه تتوقف عند الخلافات بين الزوجين
وتعديها الى افتقارهما لاسس حل المشاكل
اذا قد يكون الحب موجودا لكن استمراره صعب
الا في حال عوده الكلمه الطيبه والصبر
كسيد للمواقف عند مناقشه اي خلاف بين
الزوجين
[موسيقى]
البعض بوجه صعوبه في ايجاد شريك الحياه
تسبب مثلا اختلاف مستويات اجتماعيه لان
مثلا بيكون الشخص اصلا بالبوا واخد دسم
صلوات في الطفوله
[موسيقى]
تبقى لسه خارجه مثلا هي مش لاقي الشخص
المناسب فيها فلما تيجي تدخل في علاقه
تانيه طبيعي ان هي لسه تلاقي بقى شخص
مناسب دور على افكار زي بعض الشباب صعب
انها تفتح بيت وتقدم وتجيب ذهب وكده مشاكل
كتير اصلا مش من ناحيه واحده من نواحي
كتير
وهما دخلوا علاقه قبل كده وفشلت هم خايفين
يدخلوا علاقه تانيه والحاجه التانيه تخوف
من من اللي احنا فيه الحياه دلوقتي بقت
صعبه شويه بتمنى شريك حياته كويس معه
[موسيقى]
انا من الكويت دكتوره هيا الكندري
استشاريه علاقات عاطفيه وزوجيه وكاتبه
دكتوره يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه لماذا يواجه كثيرون دكتور اليوم
بحسب الدراسه صعوبه في ايجاد شريك حياه
اهلين صباح الخير
بخصوص صعوبه وجود او الالتقاء بشريك حياه
هو مشرق قله عدد الذكور ولا شح في عدد
الاناث ولكن خلينا نقول لغياب النوايا
الحقيقيه من وراء هذا الزواج او هذا
الارتباط
فكل من يدخل هذه التجربه يجرب حظه خلينا
نقول يعني هو ما عنده ابعاد
والاركان الاساسيه اللي ممكن تقوم عليها
نجاح هذه التجربه فبالتالي كل من يعتمد
على الطرف الاخر في انجاح هذه العلاقه
يعني ما في ما في هذه المسؤوليه والجديه
في ادنى الانسان يطور من نفسه ويغير
مفاهيمها او يطورها ويشوف مثل خط فصال او
ميزان يتوازن في الاثنين في فهم بعض من
خلال القيم من خلال الاولويات قائمه
الاولويات في العلاقات كذلك طيب دكتوره
هيا بصراحه اين المشكله ومن عند مين هل
الرجال اليوم لا يلبون طموحات المراه ام
المراه اليوم ليست على قدر تطلعات الرجل
على من المسؤوليه
والله انا اشوف المسؤوليه تلقى على كاهل
الاثنين لانها هي علاقه قائمه على شخصين
يعني ما نقدر نعتمد على طرف واحد في انجاح
لازم قلت لك مثل ما قلت لك لازم يكون في
الكفين متساويين يعني كل واحد يجب ان يقوم
بدوره طيب الدراسه تقول دكتوره انه
الطرفان اليوم
يفتقدان مهارات الحفاظ على علاقه طويله
الامد منها مهاره ذكاء الذكاء العاطفي
النقاش والتفاوض حل الخلافات بين طرفين
واداره المشكلات ما رايك بذلك ماذا تنصحين
من يبحث عن شريك صحيح صحيح انا اشوف في
قله في قله في الوعي كذلك في مهارات
التواصل الاجتماعي وكذلك مهارات الذكاء
العاطفي مثل ما قلت لك انه حتى احنا عندنا
في الثقافه بشكل عام في الوطن العربي يمكن
نشوف ان الاعتماد يلقب بشكل اكبر على
المراه بحيث ان هي تكون يعني هي محور
البيت او هي محور انه تدير هذه العلاقه
بشكل اكبر ولكن هذا يسبب ضغط اكبر لكن
الان اختل فت يعني موازين الحياه اختلفت
يعني حتى المراه نشوفها بالطلعه اكثر حق
الحياه عندها مثلا اهتمامات اخرى غير
العائله فبالتالي هي يعني مسؤوليه يعني
تتطلب جهد من الاثنين طيب دكتوره حياه لو
ما في نصيب لكن لا يمكن ان ننكر وجود الحب
في حياتنا وحتى بين الاشخاص كيف نقنع
شخصين بالزواج مثلا
انا انا عندي الوعي هو الحل لكل الامور
يعني الحب دائما موجود وانا اؤمن بالحب
واشجع على الحب وعلى الزواج كذلك ولكن انا
بعد ما ضد ان الواحد يدخل هذه التجربه فقط
لمجرد انه هو لازم يجرب هو لازم يكون
مستعد وفاهم لابعاد هذه التجربه يعني هي
مسؤوليه يعني ممكن تكون كبيره ولكن
الاشخاص او نقول الشباب مش فاهمين ابعادها
يعني ممكن الانسان يطور نفسك كذلك من
ناحيه انه مهارات التواصل انه ممكن يكتسب
عادات او مفاهيم جديده ممكن تخدم هذه
العلاقه وتستمر لفتره اطول واحنا بنشكرك
جزيل الشكر دكتوره هيا الكندري استشاريه
علاقات عاطفيه وزوجيه وكاتبه شكرا لك الله
يسلمك شكرا شكرا